louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
and even though you know it's true
[Music]
get a dog name
we're together
please
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's called the how Joe Biden sees all
the 12 year olds kind of like what's
one's been on an island and they're
really hungry and you look like a
hamburger just every single
twelve-year-old girl looks like they're
doing this on the show third share we
have pent Ellis of course working people
follow you there on the Twitter it's a
horrible Twitter yeah it's a big P for
hbi chief is terrible but comedy calm
cause y'all's comedy when funniest
comedy writers out there works with mike
Ward is of course Human Rights Tribunal
for a joke there in Canada korto black
care junior what's the line of the day
shot so the book is still a place I will
be in a couple of short weeks you're
actually going there I am gonna go to
the dishes on the honeymoon
ready yes yes if we make it out of the
bedroom something tells me you're not
making it into the bedroom question of
the day she's gonna be and she's off
with the bellboy so question sorry she's
lovely we're gonna be talking about
brian Stelter today and more media bias
kind of in the way of the run show story
but first let me ask you what she and a
maker in your opinion is the largest
festering pile of corn infested fecal
matter let me know we also have a 7 plus
1 on Joe Biden and Paul Joseph Watson
let me know before you watch the brian
Stelter segment because i know if you
yeah comment after you watch it that
we're going to be we're gonna be skewing
the death we don't want to buy yeah it's
not fair no I don't want to show you our
hand yet posit comment then come back
starting us off though is this claim
that young social media influencers now
are key to fighting terrorism in the
Middle East has come from the New York
Post according to the author youth are
authentic to one another in a way
government officials religious
authorities or parents are not and so
the reason is to fight terrorism leading
this new crop of influencers is actually
we know a popular YouTube personality
Sharia Laura welcome back to my youtube
channel this is going to be my latest
unboxing and makeup
[Laughter]
still monetized oddly enough yeah look
if you were to fight Isis well if you
want to do a good job about this how
about just being honest about Islam
every time somebody is honest about
Islam they get banned they get
demonetised and they get shouted down
left anytime you read from cover to
cover the green new deal by the way yeah
between the covers there's only four
pages it's a quick read
did you read it pen tell us no but I
don't like his tone the husband was
sharing his culture yes exactly exactly
I just haven't been you know woke enough
yet I guess yes no I didn't use them
properly I don't even not even just like
you'll never be welcome in the honeymoon
you'll be fast asleep outside the
bedroom dah bit but the bellboy is
nowhere to be seen in media news must be
executives Tulsa blow physically better
to slow news with this is what you can
expect it's slow news we have at
BuzzFeed executives Delta blow two
employees the Union this comes from a
tweet I think from one of the members of
the Union five minutes after the meeting
with the Union was scheduled to start
executives said they weren't going to
show up and of course they were very
upset let's trended for about four
minutes
in response today BuzzFeed released the
top 25 employee suicide gifts you won't
believe so they seem as though
[Laughter]
executives on this one showing up to the
meeting as well this is stupid Union
people at a terrible terrible news
outlet air quotes yeah but I mean how
else are we're also gonna find a job
unless you have a unit you if you have a
job but see us you need to hang on to it
for dear life don't piss them off they
will just fire you faster I will I love
the money anything as much as BuzzFeed
writers love doing nothing though then
again we get a lot of material from them
so maybe we do want them to stay around
that's true I also learn from them at
the male and female sea otter hold hands
right before he rapes her that's
actually what happens in real life
lights your face claws or neck copulates
the life I don't show you know they just
show them holding hands going down like
bare necessities down a river otters are
not as bad as a ground owl all right
let's not go back there yeah leave
Florida in Florida on a lighter note
therapists have seen an increase in
patients claiming to struggle with
global warming here's a clip yeah it's
not just women either it's a lot of men
couples specifically who are talking
about all of the reasons why they will
or will not have children and now
they're just considering climate change
who's gonna pay for it they're just
putting we're putting our problems now
yeah under the future generations and
they again think it's morally and
ethically irresponsible yeah this is
something I've been thinking about for
years I want my own children and I think
that would be like so much fun
there's too many people no don't
sterilize yourselves said the
association of reversed psychologists
across the earth world ever the
therapists go on to say worrying about
environmental problems can cause anxiety
and depression across across the world
really at this point no one is safe yeah
and if you see it's really a shame
happening to them he's not depressed
he's just having a good time and you
invaded his privacy
it's very unnecessary you had a point on
this pen tell us really why is she
saying people who are depressed about
climate change are more likely to be
said if you're depressed about anything
you're gonna be saying to school for
years to be able to give that diagnosis
how dare you it seems that there's a
statistical likelihood if someone is
clinically depressed that they are more
likely to be clinically depressed yes
well look here's the thing can't we just
all close our eyes for 11 years and
change and this will just all be over
apparently we only have just under 12
years so I don't know 12 that's the
thing it's just well obviously we're
doing away with all the rules from An
Inconvenient Truth and you know the the
the the bullheaded lesbian who sang the
song who sang the inconvenient truth but
I always confused them was it Sinead
O'Connor was the scenario comedy that's
I don't know I confused them there's so
many was it go Connor Lauper who's the
is it mcLaughlin
I don't look a lot different people yeah
changeable there's another redhead
lesbian with short hair who's a singer
who
I don't know I think you would know the
Spencer lets you see more cultured
because you're Greek your people created
modern culture and art it was destroyed
it was bastardizing
that's right country went bankrupt they
didn't want to retire at the ripe old
age of 38
the funniest thing about that she said I
just don't feel like it's okay that
we're passing this on to our the next
generation to our kids I'm like oh but
the crushing debt that you're passing on
totally fine right I just won't have a
planet they won't be able to stand by
the way your kids will say airplane what
was that father come sit on my knee let
me tell you about how we used to get
around they'd go up to five hundred
miles an hour oh he's just telling tall
tales he must be talking about the light
rail that only goes to 20 Wow the topic
of people who need therapy
Scientologists this came out they
considered Tom Cruise to be a deity oh
jeez it comes from page six because
that's a legitimate news source
apparently now the actors believe to be
second only to David Miscavige the
savior the sickness I hear the savior of
the free world
so please someone crucify him thank you
Tom I sort of let that ride a twist of
fate actually the cult claims were they
were actually corroborated by this
recently discovered early century
artwork of closeted us [ __ ] wrists so
if you see look this is binomial
nomenclature I thought you had something
you better say they're clear oh gosh oh
I'm so sorry
yes oh Jesus I I sincerely apologize for
that it get moved around one hell of a
wedding night gerald screw sorry I've
been thinking about that did you ever
see that by the way going clear no no I
saw we guess I did yellow I saw it on
HBO okay so crazy it is absolutely crazy
I had no idea there were enough of these
people to have a convention but
apparently there aren't they had a
convention and they had brought comp Tom
Cruise up and they said he is
responsible for
saving 1 billion souls 1 Tom Cruise by
the way saved a billion souls pushing
Scientology and by the way that's just
from the B Block segment of as Matt
Lauer interview got an award who are
these people your clip your clip you
don't even know it's like Atreus if
you've been the research is that in the
research really Tom what is psychiatry I
don't know what really you don't know
what ruling is that we're over medicated
so that's the problem is they won't
necessarily say to them because they're
crazy psycho the chair while he was
saying that he was he looked at over
medicated himself
yeah probably look I'm fine guys I'm
fine I'm fine I'm standing up I didn't
think the jumping on the couch was a big
deal studio parkour didn't help his
argument ok I don't know I didn't think
it was that big of a deal I just think
he's crazy pure I just feel like he's
really corny and out of touch Jesus no
because he's short
so Joey likes short guys are like hey
tall guys can I be included watch me
jump on the couch like no no photos week
so finally uh vice president because
he's earned that respect vice president
likely pedophile joe biden issued an
apology dish for his handy handy yes we
say handy handsy general malfeasance
blaming it all on changing cultural
norms but don't take my word for it
today i want to talk about gestures of
support and encouragement that I've made
to women and so being made the moon
culture I say kids I'm and boy show me
that blatant blew my shoulders and said
you can do this now social wars that
began to change they've shifted now and
the boundaries are protecting personal
space have been reset and again
and nipples of 14 year olds kind of
always off limits always do you shaking
hands and giving hugs by the way never
creeps people out it's the other stuff
the whispering in the ear the kissing on
the hair that's what great people out
just the sniffing of the hair well
that's pretty bad so much creepier than
kissing on yeah that's that's like
Hannibal Lecter kind of stuff you know
how you read about displays of affection
sort of in the Old Testament that's a
little bit weird and I realize that's
what they did back then like we're
washing of the feet
for example the blessing under the thigh
that's basically like symbolizing
generations but he actually means under
the loins right we're talking about
right but still nothing is as realized
and then he sniffs her hair and you're
like like oh no they're just talking
about sexual deviant
it was a different time yeah the social
norms have changed really Joe we're not
talking like from the 50s to today we're
talking like four years ago today okay
we haven't moved that far I realized
that four years ago squeezing and in
turns bosoms was a different world back
then yeah the good old days
and everybody's response to that was
like god it's such a great apology isn't
it good to see a politician just be
sincere and own up to it I do think he's
sincere I think he's completely out of
it I don't think you know I just don't
think it's right I don't think he's our
I don't think he's a rapist I don't
think it's a pedophile but I do think
that he's blaming all this seriously
creepy behavior on changing cultural
norms and that brings us to this week
seven plus one we know we don't forget
it in the channel or anything we can't
get him so this week is seven plus one
cultural norms that have changed over
the course of Joe Biden's lifetime as
explained by Vice President Joe Biden
himself number seven back in my day
there were no nanny cams tell us you
give us number six well back in my day
Stephen newspapers cost a nickel beer
cost a dime and your secretary costs 79
cents on the dollar and a pinch for good
luck there you go looks like a Disney
had a flashback to wreck-it Ralph number
five again reasons for changing cultural
norms as described by Joe Biden when I
was in college we made out with middle
schoolers all the time
number four you showed me a baby boomer
who hasn't twisted a nine-year-olds and
I'll show you a loser
said Joe Biden yeah emphasize emphasized
said Joe Biden number three back in my
day blackface was a compliment
and a turn-on you thought that maybe it
was gonna be more racially motivated but
then he goes back to his bread and
butter
Gerald why don't you hit us with that
number two back in my day forefoot
didn't have a say oh my gosh no no no
take it off Gerald Mouse boobs on this
let's just do another what's do another
one number two stop it
what made you think that you should say
this oh yeah did it again didn't I can
tell us let's wash that taste out of our
mouth number give us number two back in
my day they called it babysitter's yes
and the number one justification for
cold not justification proof of changing
cultural non just described by Joe Biden
back in my day if an ethnic bartender
complained about the environment you
just pinched her on the ends there you
go and the plus one seems almost and
related back in my day Obama would have
been my vice president you just cannot
get out of his own way I don't
understand Joe Biden yeah he's
constantly stumbling over himself
usually to try and grope a small child
this week's trivia contest winner is a
kid flanked by the way at I love lu v
clever hits who correctly named that
planet fitness was actually the gym
where stephanie crowder first debuted
only took you one visit to you know i
think you're getting a your choice also
by the way take out thank you to Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman for
sponsoring today's show all I can say is
of course we give you our word that
won't change the editorial direction
credo decisions at all but you know what
he's really bring moderate Islam into
the new world and we're all pretty
grateful to him there for it yeah yeah
okay all right we're gonna move on here
today to a show I think you're familiar
with the segment but let me give some
context first brian Stelter started yet
it doesn't matter it been able here's
the thing it's a Sloane nothing
this is going to be good no it's all
accurate but it's very awfully much like
brian Stelter so this is long overdue
for brian Stelter but the past few weeks
he's really earned it with the leftist
propaganda he's been pushing and it's
even more you know what it's just it's
time for this week's what a piece of way
to reach into the world yeah reach into
the vault to find that picture
do you have Brian stoked you don't have
him in Kansas that what he really looks
like yeah when it's a real person is a
real person on the news he has his own
show yes disgusting okay so reason
number five and this is what bothers me
most I know this should probably number
one but I think it sets up the context
most importantly this guy brian Stelter
is constantly and he doesn't even see
how transparent it is it's inadvertently
transparent he's not trying to be
transparent
he's accidentally transparent in
praising his own show his own network
he's constantly Trey's whole show it's
just about convincing you of his value
as a media dinosaur here you go and I'm
actually a defender of this cable
talk-show model I'm an avid viewer of it
course you're because news headlines are
ubiquitous these days our phones alert
us for the news so cable is more like a
rolling talk show letting people be a
part of the daily debate about how our
country should be governed and how our
world should work but here's the thing
speculation actually has value to it
helps open our own eyes helps open our
minds to what's possible I know people
like to mock cable news and moments like
this it's an easy punchline right we are
kind of standing by to find out what the
news is gonna be waiting for AG bar to
tell us something
nothing but that does have value to know
gives you a place to go a place to turn
to a recognition that you're not the
only one who wants to know
go read an online article go home go to
the pub and get crap face anything but
that yes it has value to complete
speculation devoid of sex what a piece
of [ __ ]
you you brian Stelter you use your
airtime to advocate why you need the
remaining portion of your time is there
anything less accurate than the initial
reports of breaking news you don't need
it you need to tomorrow's news wait wait
wait for it just wait with us by the way
did you know Penn tell us he's he's
straight for a rocking penis though he
lacks last credits now you think you'd
have more they think you feel a little
more whimsical yes brian Stelter you
generally don't get the story right you
nearly always get it wrong and then you
double down don't believe me yet well
we're gonna get two reasons for through
one you pieces so let's go reason number
four I should have had a language
warning it's bleeped but this is
designed with it in mind but I just
there's no other way to just Jessi
Smollett and brian Stelter and I know
he's gonna see this you're welcome ah he
blamed the synagogue shooting okay this
is reason number four
blaming synagogue shooting on fox news
anchors here you go the ridiculousness
of this rhetoric but it is effective
among some people i sir hope some of
those Fox hosts some of those
commentators take a moment take a minute
to think about their role in this
environment hopefully there's some
soul-searching right now in the wake of
this massacre what what does that do the
silent seekers he's like if we had more
immigrants they could shield the Jew
what is he talking about but you will
notice a trend as we go through these
clips
he's the news correspondent equivalent
of Christian Bale he's all occur within
the same year it's like guess his weight
step right up step back to Thanksgiving
see
so still to here you argued that Fox
News referred to immigrants as invaders
and that the somehow drove someone to
shoot I guess a bunch of a bunch of Jews
that's what he's trying to say Fox News
is responsible for shooting Jews
Mohammed by the way not responsible for
anyone having sex with six-year-old
girls or you know killing Jews as and
call for his last words that would be a
misinterpretation of kill the Jew
insensitive it was a smear campaign
campaign from Big D you have to look at
the original language yeah it still says
kill but yeah pretty much very much
okay how about this call me when CNN
when you do a segment mr. Stelter on how
ill Anoma or Linda Sarsour they're
responsible for eight crimes gangsters
let's just you know people say it's not
fair to compare Muhammad okay current
figures but Brian I don't think you will
that would require you to be consistent
which you must never are and is
ironically what are the strong suits of
most pieces of so it's seems as though
you've missed the boat even on that by
the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed on YouTube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
anymore
also bookmark the page because
notifications may not work anymore let
us know if you're getting them best
thing is to join a lot of credit calm
slash mug Club you get a full catalog
full Daily Show and of course subscribe
on iTunes and rate us there because we
might be polled who knows okay we reason
number three this one should I mean I
almost could just roll the clip but let
me just set it up and hate for people
who are listening in the car he pushed
him he is a presidential candidate
seriously repeatedly here you go
President Obama also had a lot of TV
star power and that helped him pre Trump
but trumpets more evidence of this and
looking at the 2021 reason why I'm
taking you seriously as a contender is
because of your presence on cable news
really put a black Garrett soundboard
hit that that one needs that's a big
that seems like a prime Stelter one he
would blame it on the dog but not like
as a joke that's cute
like it's the dog he'd be like no it's
seriously the dog I think we need to put
it down to cover up his own traffic to
the vet and have the dog put down just
so he wouldn't be blamed he with
everybody he's specifically only taking
him seriously because of his appearances
on CNN they can't go back to reason but
I think that you'd be a great president
because I want to remain employed and
you're on my show that means you're
important otherwise you wouldn't be on
my show all wrong it's cuz he likes his
hair there's camaraderie there
by the way the only reason heaven Adi
was it was because you see over a
hundred times in 10 weeks a hundred
times in ten weeks if you want to this
is kind of like what bill bill maher
said uh if I want to know the Trump
colluded with the Russians I just turn
on my TV I have I see yourself
yes saying it this is like brian Stelter
saying the reason have an i it would be
great is because he's on all of the
important shows well which shows my show
he's on my show therefore he should be
President so it could be on more shows
when he's president which shows my show
I think he should be on my show so it
becomes president so it comes back on my
show completely 100 percent straight by
it how delusional do you have to be by
the way to be that's like to be sucking
so badly in the ratings like you could
just look at the numbers and still think
you're that important well it's because
speculation is important also dead air
as we wait for news about a Russia
collusion case that never materialized
is important it's super important what
are you gonna say what is that go-getter
of a naughty up to now who himself is
equally a piece of now been arrested for
trying to extort Nike for 50 million
dollars he's taking one of those prison
readiness classes right yes here's what
you do and when he went in to put his
belongings in the Ben he said wait
haven't you seen me on Stelter and they
said sir no one's seen you on this but
he does come in every few weeks for
voluntary conjugal visits he just wants
all to smile on their face reason number
two he blamed it at the female prisons
clearly right okay yes I'm really not
just weaponizing sexuality here of
course I had my to everyone in this room
honestly okay if you were to watch that
would you take the guy straight I would
have questions well you had the worst
gaydar in the world Pantelis I'm gonna
bother you I didn't think he was a
person okay okay too cute daddy woman no
you would think he wouldn't think he
straight my wife she's my wife cuz I
didn't have to watch if more than five
seconds your wife has one of the word I
have the worst gaydar
yes you have it worse than my wife no
yeah
you do there's this friend in the past
you some hot sex with George Michael in
a porta potti and you stable no he said
don't spoil it okay
reason number two and this one's pretty
obvious he blamed Russia right that he
blamed Donald Trump for the Russian
collusion conspiracy that would seem bad
enough but here's the thing that's
actually not number two here all right
he actually blamed the conspiracy itself
on Trump
so after Stelter was pushing the
narrative for two years on his show
because speculation is super important
and then it was completely blown up he
doesn't apologize he blames the
conspiracy for being created by Trump
here you're gonna hear this from the
right for the next days and weeks to
come that the presses basically made all
this up to take down President Trump but
the press is just following a trail that
Trump created so it caused it
journalists were following a trail that
Trump created what it led to nowhere
like Donald Trump like this is like okay
this is gonna be one of the greatest
tricks of political history all right
they're gonna hang this URL by deck and
it's gonna impede my presidency
I've almost gonna get impeached and
that's it there's one who did it take
this field I see for example it was a
fake document created by a Democrat PR
firm the meet you spread and by the way
don't he went on to say that the rush of
collusion and it was basically the
entire premise of the show by the way
named
reliable sources ironic all day watch
this clip
welcome back to reliable sources where
everyday we're trying to keep track of
the drip drip drip of the Russia
investigations something else it's a
piece of walking down a trail of leaving
crumbs to find his way home I can't keep
track of all much it takes a big pair of
balls to be able to come out and say it
wasn't you who did it and keep keep
watching this guys because this is this
is gonna break I know it I mean he's
really trying to cut it off at the past
and he just doesn't know how no no
listen they're gonna say that the
Russian collusion thing is not true
that it didn't happen but these are the
same people who don't believe I'm
straight
also McDonald Trump was the one who did
this Donald Trump was the one who set
the trail of breadcrumbs when Roger
stone met with Russians and sent a tweet
to Julian Assange and by the way why was
Donald Trump to him when he had Kid Rock
out in American flag pens so at one
point had sex was well Anderson who
happens to be friends once again Julian
Assange why are you leave it's
practically a bakery what oh no you're
gonna blame me now I used to reinvent
himself he's gonna shave it completely
ooh
tattoo guitars in flames and call
himself helter skelter number one Joe by
and they don't really need to go in this
order but just because he was also in
our previous pls segment defending Jesse
Smollett now again it's not just about
the Jesse Smollett hate crime being
exposed as a hoax um that would be too
reductive we wouldn't want to be
reductive when addressing brian Stelter
because he brian Stelter i think of him
as a nuanced issue you know like a
bridge troll so he claimed like they're
not all bad everybody else
he claimed that news organizations were
really careful oh and then it was all so
this is what it's not just that he
rushed to judgment he claimed that the
news didn't rush it was only random
people on Twitter
who rushed adjustment there was a rush
to judgment I think it was mostly in the
celebrity press and among activists and
among Twitter people I think it was a
really careful reporting by news
organizations but it all gets lumped in
together at the end of the day it all
gets lumped together in the minds of
many people wrong again you piece of
[ __ ]
unseen from Brooke Baldwin
to April right I think you've Don Lemon
no yes absolutely Don Lemon he actively
helped to push the small and hoax and
how do you know that we're telling the
truth because now Stelter is claiming
even today that we may never know what
happened on that fateful night the
narrative it's once again changed from
victim you know to villain back to
victim it's been very confusing that the
line was saying people don't know what
to believe and we may never really know
what happened on the street that night
in Chicago well I guess it remains a
mystery to all of us
satting off good night and I'm a piece
of he's confused by on and off switches
I can't believe that we may never know
or you may never know this is journalism
this is news that we're supposed to
trust this is what's in airports around
the world I know are you serious if
nobody only watch news at airports
we're screwed hate us put the notice
under the file of Isis recruitment tapes
yes the D okay by the way so we may
never know okay let me kind of rattle
off why that might not be true okay the
DEA specifically said that small it was
guilty you were just letting him off
because he served 16 hours of community
service we have video of the Nigerian
brothers purchasing the materials using
the attack we have a testimony that
Jesse paid them and we have the check
with which he actually paid them this
story didn't have a turd in the
punchbowl from the beginning the whole
punch bowl was nothing but she he wrote
a memo line fake attack haha able to
fake checks cash and they said now they
trying to say that the war white face
are confused in yeah after yeah like get
out it's like the oldest sitcoms where
it's like you know the person is coming
in dressed in disguise only someone else
wears the same disguise and it turns out
it's their mom like I thought
it was just some other random masked
white person attacking me in the exact
same method I planned it with my
Nigerian brothers also I'm pretty happy
I'm sure it happened on According to Jim
but everything's happened on According
to Jim they know how to blaze trail so
here's the thing you know what you're
the brian Stelter you're the according
to Jim of news
ouch stupid no that's true what I don't
understand then made this decision
the reason brian Stelter has he gets to
go out to continually advocate for his
job right really he has to he doesn't
just have a portion of his show watch
his show this is my challenge to you I'm
sorry but watch his show and tell me if
he goes a single segment without somehow
advocating for the importance of his job
and he has to do it because of the blind
spot that networks like CNN have they
have to I don't
please someone tell me fat yep
check talentless yep seemingly gay check
uninteresting yep no one will watch
check you have a show sir they like you
were he's proof positive about the blind
spot of media they actually thought his
show would work someone someone lost to
brian Stelter
there was a call back imagine being in
that room there's people sitting there
with their sides at the callback and
they're all everyone there right they're
nervous but they all feel pretty
confident that he's not gonna get it
they're playing the shelter and then
they see him on television later that
week and they say no and then they never
tell a soul that they went out for that
job no I think I didn't get to go that
day I was sick do you never tell this
story I auditioned for a show on it was
on I think was on YTV can't remember
this yeah why TV like the neverending
story they did a TV show yeah terrible I
audition there was in the show was not
any better so I auditioned for this show
and I auditioned for this friend named
Luke okay and um I remember I stayed up
that night they said we've narrowed it
down to you and one other person thought
this is gonna be my big break never any
story my TV
human they call and it was about
midnight and they call it my parents
come into my bedroom and they said hey
you know we're sorry kid you know they
they didn't pick you they what who'd
they pick and they said they said they
were going more ethnic swear to God who
comes on the show the little Indian kid
with a mustache at ten years old he was
clearly the worst actor when we were
going in and mixing and matching because
we read for the different parts and it
was very embarrassing because I had told
a couple of my friends and I was really
they told me I was a favorite to get it
and then they said you didn't get it who
got it it's still less embarrassing and
losing out to brian Stelter that's how
bad and how much of a piece of I think
he is if you think I'm out of line
please let me know we'll come back right
after this with Paul Joseph Watson
[Music]
okay okay oh okay that hurts that hurts
oh that's enough that's it Oh time ugh
um come on there's enough no as we go
about our days consumed with the hustle
and bustle of modern life it's easy to
forget that an evil lurks among us an
evil so sinister
we'd perhaps rather forget the Athene to
Nakul area known by its common name the
burrowing or ground owl it lives in
parts of North and South America
infesting your grasslands deserts and
increasingly your neighborhoods flying
in the face of evolutionary biology
unlike his birds of prey brethren the
burrowing owl doesn't take to the skies
for his hunt or habitat but instead
decides to live in the dirt his decision
to eschew all of his natural adaptive
advantages as a winged animal has
resulted in him taking up more real
estate which could be used for your
local parks beaches or places of
business the burrowing owls arrogance as
displayed by his choice to live in the
dirt like a groundhog rather than one of
God's majestic hunters of the heavens is
surpassed only by his boiling hot temper
what a dick join mud club at louder with
Crider dot-com slash mud club and help
us exterminate the ground out today what
do you need besides a miracle
guns lots of them I'm Trinity no you pan
tell us your Trinity is that all you
need yeah this is the new wall through
all steel frame q5 match red dot ready
it is all I need
the all steel Walter q5 match it has
good balance about a five point six
pound trigger pull
try the Walther
[Music]
are you doing an African dance I don't
know they're really trying to make this
is African yeah I don't know many many
fold black men who were Lobster Hawaiian
shirts hey what's wrong with lobsters
man there's a lot wrong with do you know
I actually think there's still laws in
the book and watch people's the suckers
damage me for this they're gonna say
it's a race thing but actually there are
laws in the books I think still in
Maryland where you can only feed slaves
crustaceans a certain amount of times
per week some like two times per week
because you should be considered slave
food yeah that's messed up that's the
his I don't know why it's still on the
books but you know I guess they just
never got rid of it I also think that in
Georgia it's the illegal to wear funny
hats it's scared children they're very
silly laws out there I learned this on a
Saturday school spot it was a Saturday
after school it's not really after
school because it's Saturdays everyone
to know it was on it was on a Canadian
show called Popular Mechanics and Elisha
Cuthbert
was a host in that show she was her
little sister was in my grade she did
not like me very much but the next man I
like very much he's on the show I always
play a game before he comes on it's
called guess his haircut because it's
always changing but his backgrounds
always the same you know I'm on Twitter
at prison planet he has a new website
now summit dot news Paul Joseph Watson
how are you sir I'm good Steven good to
be back in a while I'm glad I'm glad to
see you here and now you got the new
hairdo here so either Samantha bee will
accuse you of being a Nazi or you're the
high school bully in two years ago about
Eric trump having the same hairstyle and
that it was a fashi hairstyle so I've
kept - ever since I feel like it was
different last time maybe it's just
freshly shorn which is better than
whenever John Kasich will get his hair
cut he looked like the the baby eagle
you know a little kind of sprout so
there's the two week mark for men women
don't understand these things well the
volume low Steve and I got the volume
I'll get away with yes yes so don't ask
you get a recent video regarding
obviously the race recent how do you how
do you pronounce Brunei how do you print
it I say Brunei oz Brunei night yeah
that's probably correct I just wanted to
trick you just like I often say Mike
even though it's Nike but that's because
I'm mildly [ __ ] so everyone's been
talking about them and they're they're
stoning to death their new anti-lgbt
laws it wasn't a surprise to me and you
did a video on this about the LGBT laws
in Islamic countries people can go see
it on your YouTube
I'll explain it to people who may not
know the correlation well it's obvious
it's actually quite mild in Brunei Steve
and compared to some of the other
countries for this Brunei law you can
only be stoned to death if there are
four witnesses that see the gay sex
taking place so I guess they must have
to have some kind of orgy yes it's quite
a high bar it's quite a high bar for it
but in other countries that the bar is a
lot lower obviously it takes you know in
Islamic countries one male witness to
impugn women generally speaking well
yeah I'd made a video yesterday called
Islam versus LGBT choose your character
Islam seems to be winning right now but
I went through the list of countries
that stone or execute gay people to
death Afghanistan Iran Mauritania Sudan
all roughly 93 to 99 percent Muslim so
I'm kind of getting some kind of
correlation there Stephen between these
Muslim majority countries and these kind
of laws that they introduced and I would
imagine the remaining 7% is the state of
Utah because of those Mormons correct
yeah but why what I brought into it yeah
in fact Nigeria is like 52 that Muslim
that there are some Christians there
that they also have it that's the lowest
this 50% right but the correlation is
this oppression Olympics war between
Islam and LGBT because in the UK while
all this is happening we have several
schools now where it's basically 98
percent Muslim kids in places like
Birmingham in the Midlands in the UK
where they have these LGBTQ curriculums
which are going to be compulsory across
the entire country by 2020 teaching
relationship advice to children as young
as 5 it's not as bad as it sounds at the
outset it's basically showing them a
book where a family has two moms or two
dads it's that kind of thing so yeah you
know Christians would disagree with that
it's not literally teaching
five-year-olds how to put condoms on and
stuff like that which we have that
separately but by the way but yes it's
not that so they've had massive protests
outside all these UK schools parents
literally pulling their kids out of the
schools and obviously the progressives
the LGBT crowd who protested Trump when
he visited London
because he's obviously anti-gay even as
he wraps himself in a rainbow flag
obviously you know they were out on the
street marching with their banners this
weekend obviously they're gonna be
marching on the Embassy of Brunei
actually no they said nothing whatsoever
so again you've got this massive
disconnect between the population of a
country bear in mind 52 percent of
Muslims living in the UK literally want
to put gay people in cages 52 percent
think homosexuality should be illegal
we have Sharia patrols and even CNN
report on this where gay people are told
by Muslim gangs to leave areas because
they're gay we have acid attacks outside
gay nightclubs now and the LGBT life a
fact check you know I think you're
actually confused acid attack is the
name of Birmingham's hippest gay
nightclub yeah why it's interested in
semen because we had the first Muslim
gay marriage in the UK last year and
within about 24 hours the gay Muslim
couple that got married was inundated
with acid attack threats again from the
from the tolerant precious Muslim
population who the LGBT Lobby rallies
behind every available opportunity so we
have this disconnect between them
supporting people who literally want to
throw them off buildings or best put
them in prison meanwhile attacking the
dangerous right-wing core actually a lot
of gay people are now coming on board
with the right-wing because they see a
common threat yeah because putting them
in prison where they'll meet more
radical Islam ization and gay sex
that'll fix the problem let's put the
gays in prison so there's more gayness
is this is not very well thought out no
I do wonder this though do people across
the pond do they not know that President
Trump was the first president sworn into
office who was pro gay marriage as he
now Brocklin was against it and then he
was for it and it kind of evolved
throughout his presidency Donald Trump
is the first president to ever enter
into office as Pro gay marriage did they
not know that when they were protesting
him as a homophobe no they don't read
Steve and they don't read below the
surface of what they're told you know
it's like with Ron v Wade he said I'm
just gonna leave it and
again now he's anti-abortion they're
still whining about Mike Pence's gay
conversion therapy meanwhile you have
literal dictatorships in the Middle East
saying they're going to stone gay people
to death but I mean Steve and I you know
considering what the kind of heat I get
from the media I'm actually considering
converting to Islam because I've thought
why not just embrace what the media
labels me at this point yeah I mean they
call me a conspiracy theorist despite
the fact that for the past six years
I've made videos debunking conspiracy
theories have you seen so you know
belief in all kinds of wacky conspiracy
theories is totally prevalent across the
Muslim world polls show it you know I've
been called an anti-semite for
criticizing George Soros it's quite
well-known that Muslims aren't big fans
of Jews I've been called transphobic for
saying that allowing men in women's
bathrooms is probably going to cause
problems and you know in the Islamic
world you get trans people being
attacked on a regular basis in Paris
yesterday there was a case of that a
trans woman who was attacked by a group
of Algerians so you know believing in
conspiracy theories anti-semitism
transphobia if those are all really
dreadful beliefs as the media says a lot
of Muslims hold those same beliefs what
every single converts a Muslim only
enjoying the winning team and we've
tried to clarify two difference between
Islam and Muslims so not all Muslims
obviously hold all those beliefs that
being said every single Muslim who
claims a Muslim does believe in a
conspiracy theory and that they have to
believe that the Jews subverted the
Bible they have to believe that going
back to the blessing from Abraham it was
a lie because of the Jews Farrakhan was
just talking about this last week I
think we ran a clip on one of the shows
we said that Jesus was never crucified
he only came because it was not time to
end the Jewish people something like
that I mean I know it's kind of sounding
Bill Cosby rapey but I don't get my
point the entire Islamic faith is
predicated on the conspiracy theory that
the Jews lied about the blessing to the
oldest son and I'm amazed that we don't
talk about that more if we're going to
talk about ideas and toxic religions the
second you know you can't we just say
for tegmental a brahmic religions this
is the one that says all the other guys
were liars specifically the Jews that
seems like offense you're starting off
for
it could be problematic to use your
terms okay it's just the disconnect
though Stephen we literally have the
Islamic call to prayer being broadcast
in Trafalgar Square central London now
we have as I put in the video left-wing
progressives and LGBT groups not only
going out with their banners and saying
we're against Islamophobia
they literally chan allahu akbar and the
major streets in major cities in germany
in front of all their LGBT friends
meanwhile you've got muslims who attend
these gay rallies and insult them in
arabic call them all manner of horrific
homophobic slurs but again you know the
oppression Olympics table Muslims are
above gay people so they have to align
with the Muslims
to fight the common enemy which is you
and I yes apparent well not you anymore
because you've converted to Islam so you
know hats on to you that was a clever
move good good strategy on your part how
funny would it be if during the Muslim
call to prayer European gays just
created a flash mob you know that would
that would be a little bit a little bit
distasteful but you know I give them a
slow clap let me let me ask you this why
do you think people are surprised about
this recent law considering how many
anti-gay laws there are across the
Islamic world I'll be honest I was
surprised when I read people were
outraged in any capacity specifically
you know in Hollywood they were saying
let's let's boycott these hotels like oh
really okay so let's boycott whatever it
is no the the and as Dubai they were
listing all these opulent expensive
hotels and I guess they expect Middle
America to go well all right I'm not
going to be staying at the end s Dubai
anymore they say they won't get another
penny out of me why do you think people
were surprised at this I think most
people ignored it Stephen it wasn't a
really big stories already disappeared
there are a few tweets Ellen DeGeneres
etc they're not gonna go and Don their
tea hats and be out in the streets are
there it's gonna disappear after a few
days but again this this is a major
problem because you've got places like
Paris in France where the Muslim
population is now up to eight nine
percent minimum those are the official
stats you have Muslim preachers in
Palestine saying we're going to turn
France into the Islamic caliphate we're
taking over we're having children and
demographics just show it's happening if
you want to talk about integration it's
it's simply not working you do have
these no-go areas despite the media the
fact the media still calls them a
conspiracy theory you had after the
Paris massacre in 2015 the area of
molenbeek in Brussels which is an
Islamic no-go area I was kicked out of
it where they hid one of the Paris
Massacre terrorists for weeks and weeks
and weeks before he was able to be
caught by police so it's not just the
Muslims who hold these extreme beliefs
it's the ones who protect the others
that do and that's why there's such a
big problem with integration in Europe
and why it's going downhill in a hurry
well let's scale back while we're
talking about integration right let's
scale back let's remove extremism from
the table because that's always what
people try to say well there are
extremists in any religion okay you just
mentioned was it the stat something like
52% of Muslims in the UK support
imprisonment for gays was that the step
that you yeah it's done yeah so would
that be considered fringe extreme I
guess my question is because it's a
little bit different you guys are
further along the trail in the UK than
here the United States do English people
see that as extreme do they say well
hold on a second this isn't fringe I
have a problem at 52% of people think we
should imprison gay people I have a
problem if they're pulling their kids
out because there's a book with two
mommies or two daddies or is it ignored
well if you look at that exact poll that
was a couple of years ago as a channel 4
poll and they surveyed the whole
population the whole population was
about 10% thought that homosexuality
should be illegal but when you drill
down into the Muslim population it was
52 so it's shared by a minority of Brits
but it is a very small minority but then
you can you can look at other things
like support for suicide bombings under
certain circumstances and it still is
high even in Western countries as twenty
thirty percent in some countries and
again those are the ones who will admit
to it in a poll if you think of the ones
who actually do believe that but won't
admit swear in a poll for fear of
reprisals or whatever then the numbers
are probably even higher so it is it's a
massive problem that there is a huge
lack of integration and it is mainly
again impacting white working-class
people in
so when these middle-class leftists who
by the way when they get up on Twitter
and virtue signal about how much they
love mass migration even in London you
can look at exactly where they live and
there are not that many large majority
white Aires in London left they always
choose to live in the whitest areas
possible you see the same trend in
countries like Sweden the most Pro
migrant politicians live in the whitest
areas possible with the least migrants
you see that across the board with all
these celebrities in the United Kingdom
so it's like as long as they can still
pay their nanny like 10 pounds an hour
to look after their kids or their
cleaner ten pounds an hour right that's
really all they care about then they get
up on Twitter and virtue signal about it
to cover themselves though I wanted to
but that's a good point about the whole
so that people did these are where
people are feel comfortable answering
these questions and polls they the same
problem with women who'd been groped by
Joe Biden there wasn't a high answer
rate final question before we go it is
summit dot news people can follow you on
twitter at prison planet what's your
opinion on joe biden just creepy out of
touch changing social norms well the the
main story for me is not the women
that's bad enough but it's the children
i mean you've seen the creepy joe biden
video probably that i put out
either joe biden is just you just really
likes children or joe biden really likes
children
yeah it's disconnect I find legitimate
questions behind it I showed it to a
professional who works with abused
children and she basically said all the
signs were there now obviously there's
no evidence of anything but it's it's
creeping on the less yeah trunk just put
out a tweet about 45 minutes ago with
the the meme video of Joe Biden creeping
up behind him there I was you know
absolutely felt down over that but let's
not forget Stephen this was his advisor
his spokesman bit Biden spokesman said
this was created by right-wing trolls no
it was the Washington Post in 2015 that
first coined the term creepy Joe Biden
this didn't come from right-wing fever
swamps it came from his public on-camera
behavior and that apology video was
mealy-mouthed it was pathetic it wasn't
an apology at all I thought it was
hilarious all right that summit dot news
at prison planted on Twitter mister Paul
Joseph Watson thank you
for being here sir I'm glad to see that
you're well it's beer thanks Steven
see you soon we'll be back after this
and now it's time for comedy spotlight
with Billy bird on the ground owl all
right listen dude can we take a minute
to I can talk about the ground
owl okay listen all right listen I I
like animals all right okay I'm not
saying that we should can exterminate
all species I know some environmentalist
right now are gonna lose their mind you
shouldn't be talking about insane okay
would you just hold your horses for a
second but what I am saying is when it
comes to the final solution for ground
owls the worst idea right listen it's an
owl it's not a in flight this bird okay
it has the gift of flight this perch can
fly and it burrows in the ground like an
earth wahda with crowdy shop.com
supporting free speech since 2000 and
something with people being then from
social media left and right you can now
purchase this D platform this
limited-edition louder with
photoshop.com t-shirt
signifying you're insubordinate to
Authority and requests for them to kiss
your ass and lick your bladder with
Photoshop calm today ladies and
gentlemen do yourselves a favor and join
the mud club go - louder with crowder
calm / mug and join the club unless
you're a communist in which case we
don't need you and we don't want you
back to you Steven yeah well they can go
they can get the respect to Greece it's
a slash mug Club it's not just mug
there's a club is it's okay well you
know what we could have but we didn't
really have the web developers because
it's very low budget as you clearly see
by a lot of the sketches on the show and
the fact that we're importing Greek
Montreal errs ladder with credit
accomplished mug Club not only do you
get hand etched hand-painted mug you get
the Daily Show all kinds of additional
content the full blaze catalog and of
course if you're purchasing a fire and
we just recommend that you try the
walther because they're better they're
better we can't say they're better than
all the other firearms out there but I
think so and they have
the balls to support the show Malcolm
and Walter there you go you're welcome
that's my gift to the world
[Music]
[Music]
it was called the alcoholic who doesn't
understand the concept of liquidity or
um no or gases because even then he open
his mouth to breathe after he was upset
that the alcohol poured into the water
and then he suffocated I was trying to
climb the the dominance hierarchy really
and I got pulled back down well he
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
everybody you can follow him Pantelis
comedy has been here Paul Joseph Watson
pain talisman so funny yeah great
and he's so he's so good having a
writers room Michael he worked with Mike
ward quite a bit and by the way should
support them at compound media I think
that's where they do their uh their
daily show if I'm not mistaken
yes abuse but when we were looking for
some writers you know because you tried
this all myself for a long time yeah
Mike Ward said no I can't do it but he
said this guy pent Ellis was one of the
few comedians who is actually very funny
and very disciplined and will be
consistent show up and he's a joy to
work with and I used to hate that sound
the Montreal Greek sound I hated it and
now when I hear that makes me homesick I
mean it's like they say you're gonna
miss about me when I'm never knew about
it
like what my wife doesn't that really
annoys me she's like that's what you're
gonna miss most about me when I'm gone
and she usually wins the argument with
them because and I feel bad all right
clothes they save me here so for context
here some people you may not know we do
these tough love slash life advice
segments on the daily show behind the
paywall mutt clubbers know this but
those of you who've not joined it a lot
of credit I come slash mug Club may not
and we received some pretty funny yeah
requests emails letters and sometimes
some not so funny requests for sure and
this week I received one from a young
man who had gone blind later in life
remember this and he was feeling pretty
depressed which is which is normal but a
portion of his first letter that he sent
implied that he didn't really want to go
on living which is not normal which is
not healthy and obvious anyone out there
who's actually suicidal even thinking
about harming themselves please do seek
out the help of a professional
I recommend actually even if you're not
if you're not at that level I think that
everyone should should do therapy
particularly couples counseling if
you're married but um we did our best to
try and help him on the show and you
know what the advice that we we provide
is the same that we provide in the show
week after week about setting goals for
yourself
long finding long finding you're kind of
your purpose your calling making
measurable progress toward those goals
self-improvement every day mmm nothing
new not reinventing the wheel but I
received a follow-up letter this week
and I wanted to read it for you dear mr.
Crowder this comes from the gentleman
who blind gentleman who wouldn't blind
that later in life I wanted to thank you
so much for the generous gesture you've
done oh well this sons this sound
self-raising enough if we sent him a
Mudd Club it's not that big a deal
it touched my heart and was really one
of them okay as a quick aside the
conservative movement has done more to
help me as an other person than the
progressive movement that claims to
represent me I watched the episode in
which you answered my letter and I'm
really thinking about what you said and
how I can work toward it what you said
about making goals and finding my dreams
really hit me I had my dreams but I
guess I never really applied myself to
achieving them because I didn't believe
in myself enough basically my big pie in
the sky dream is to be a professional
musician and to be able to live off of
what I'm good at well my more grounded
dream is to be as independent as
possible with my own career and to live
a normal life like everyone else you
gotta keep in mind he went blind I think
at 13 years of age of course the former
is far less realistic than the latter
but I'm going to work towards both of
them despite how difficult it may be for
me I already upload my own original
music and covers to YouTube but the way
I've been treating is not as committed
as someone who would really want it the
latter dream have already taken steps
toward applying to school to get my
bachelor's degree in the fall so I know
I'll just have to not lose sight of the
goal blind guy lose sight
I think he sees the irony there thank
you for everything you've done and
hopefully I'll be able to improve myself
in situation with using the advice
you've given me also the blind jokes are
hysterical to me and I have no problem
with you making them including at my
expense because the irony of blind
people using the words like see is not
lost on me and making jokes at my own
expense and so I'm fine with anyone else
doing the same thank you and thanks for
giving me a good place to start moving
forward sincerely redacted like the
Mulder report we don't want to give out
people's personal name and the reason I
read this is not that you not to even
try and percent like I'm some sort of
sage with unique advice a matter of fact
it's the exact opposite I read this to
you first for because it's really
touching and if you're listening
redacted I'm really glad that we could
help if we did I read this to show you
that you know in our day to day problems
all of us are a whole lot closer to each
other than you think and so are the
solutions I mean I know all of us were
talking with us after that
episode the life advice we were all
sitting you're going like man could you
imagine going blind yeah oh my gosh that
must be just incomprehensibly difficult
but you know what there are people out
there who are dealing with that who
might say the same thing about something
you're dealing with it could be some
other kind of it could be the loss of a
loved one and things for both of you for
all of you the fix is still pretty much
the same gratitude goals consistency
measurable progress things we talk about
every week I think it's also probably
what connects us more strongly than
anything else
meaning you me everyone on this team
everyone watching or listening this and
I realize that in in in doing these
segments specifically it's it's not our
political affiliation it's not a
religious affiliation or audience is
pretty evenly split among atheist
libertarians conservative Christians we
have sort of classical liberal
contrarians we have some Twitter trolls
we can see all this through our
analytics what connects all of us I
think because it really has been a haven
where people hang out and it's been
really inspiring for me to see as the
audience grows I think what connects all
of us is that each and every one of you
has baggage okay everyone everyone got
their thing in some burns are bigger
than others but not necessarily
sometimes they're just different and
when I hear from you when I see the
comments when I get letters like this it
makes me realize the bond the kinship
that we share most is that I see a group
of people who are looking to improve
themselves and I see a group of people
who are looking to improve themselves
through truth you know it's not a truth
that can be packaged in a soundbite it's
not a truth that can just be completely
explained in the closing seconds of this
segment and that's because everyone at
least in this Enclave as I see it we're
all seeking to improve ourselves not
through our truth not through my truth
through the truth and I think that's why
our retention rate we've been blessed
we've talked about this or retention
rate is so high and we're so grateful I
think that's why when your subscription
feed stops working you get notifications
when those stop working you guys
bookmark or you join up at mug Club I
can we can see it we can see all of this
to our analytics and I really appreciate
and yeah you know when it comes to the
only truthful way to self improvement
just like we see what this gentleman
who's going through unbelievable turmoil
I can't imagine going blind but any of
you it comes back to fundamentals
gratitude goals consistency measurable
progress and you know listen I'm not
guy who has all the answers I don't even
have most of them I want to be really
clear about this I'm just someone here
who's seeing the truth same as you are
and I really genuinely appreciate all of
you doing it with me blind or those with
psychics
I don't know how inspiring that is but
thanks I appreciate it and as long as
you keep trying so will we see you next
week
[Music]